الليلة عاد دوني بإلقاء نظرة على كيف
يمكن للذكاء الاصطناعي أن يزيف أصواتنا بما في ذلك مرحباً يا
أمي ،
أبدو مختلفًا عنك ، نعم لقد
قلت للتو لسنيد أنني قلت لست بحاجة إلى
بعض الأمريكيين ،
هذا ليس أنا في الواقع ، هذا صوت
صُنع بواسطة الكمبيوتر ،
يا إلهي ، هل أنت جاد ،
نعم ، أنا آسف لحدوث
انفجار في الأصوات المزيفة والأصوات التي يتم
إنشاؤها من خلال
تقنية الذكاء الاصطناعي ، هذه
نسخة مستنسخة من صوت والتر وايت ،
هذه نسخة مستنسخة من
صوت ليوناردو دي كابريو  كل ما تحتاجه هو
تسجيل دقيقتين لصوت أي شخص
ويمكنك جعل الأمر يبدو كما لو أنه
قال أي شيء حتى
أندرسون كوبر لقد أتينا إلى جامعة كاليفورنيا في
بيركلي اليوم للتحدث إلى هاني فريد
خبير الطب الشرعي الرقمي حول مدى
سهولة ذلك.  من المؤكد أن وضع الكلمات في
أفواه الآخرين أمر ممتع للغاية ،
لكنه أيضًا أمر مخيف حقًا ، وأعتقد أنه
بمجرد أن تضع جانباً عامل التذبذب هذا ،
لا أعتقد أن الأمر يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً للنظر
في المخاطر ، فهذه هي وولف بليتسر آني
فريد أنت في The Situation Room والذي
يقول أن هذا أمر جيد من خلال تحميل
بضع دقائق مني
وأصوات بعض زملائي إلى خدمة صوت AI
تمكنت من إنشاء بعض
المنتجات المزيفة المقنعة بما في ذلك هذه الصورة من Anderson
Cooper Donnie O'Sullivan  قطعة هراء حقيقية وهي أن
الذكاء الاصطناعي يفعلها حقًا هذا أمر
جيد ، نعم أندرسون رجل جيد حقًا
لأن أندرسون ليس لديه
لهجة أيرلندية غبية ، حيث واجهت التكنولوجيا
صعوبة مع لهجتي الأيرلندية ، لكننا
قررنا أن نضعها في الاختبار النهائي
مع  والداي أنا على وشك محاولة
الاتصال بأمي في أيرلندا
ومعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكاني خداعها بهذا
الصوت ، نعم أعتقد أنني سأكون
ناجحًا ، أنا متوترة ، أنا متوترة مثل يدي على ما
يرام ،
مرحبًا يا
أمي مرحبًا  دوروثي ، كيف حالك للتو ، لقد
انتهيت للتو من تصوير قصتنا هنا ،
سأذهب إلى المطار في فترة من الوقت
يبدو أنه تأخير في الهاتف توني ، هل
يمكنني أن أقول مرحباً سريعًا لأبي ،
كيف حالك هنا ، مرحباً أبي ،
كيف
حالك للتو؟  انتهينا من تصوير قصتنا
هنا ،
سأذهب إلى المطار بعد فترة من الوقت
سيعود ، حيث
يلعب كاري في نهاية هذا الأسبوع ،
واصل والدي محادثة
مع AI dhoni حول كيفية
لعب فريق كرة القدم الخاص بنا في Kerry مباراة في
نهاية الأسبوع في نهاية المطاف  كان عليّ أن أكون نظيفًا يا
أبي ، سأعطيك مكالمة أفضل لاحقًا ،
هل يمكنك إعادتي إلى أمي
لثانية كان والداي يعلمان أن شيئًا ما كان
معطلاً ولكن في النهاية ما زالا وقعوا في
ذلك ، أعني بعضًا من ذلك
لأنني ذهبت  يا صاح ، قلبي كان
نصفه في البداية ، أنا آسف ، الجهاز
مضحك للغاية ،
سأتصل بك لاحقًا أبي ،
وداعاً ، هذا ليس كلاسيكيًا ، أمي تبدو
وكأن هناك شيئًا ما خطأ في ابني ،
فالوالد يبدو وكأن كل شيء على ما يرام
وأود أن أغلقه  خارج حفل اليوم
بسؤال إذا تم إعطاؤك
خيارًا ، هل ستختار الحصول على
لحم خنزير مقدد غير محدود ولكن لن تكون هناك المزيد من ألعاب الفيديو
ستزيف تسجيلات بايدن وترامب التي
تنتشر عبر الإنترنت ، يقول فريد إن هذا
قد يكون شيئًا يجب أن يكون حذرًا من الذهاب
إلى انتخابات 2024 عندما  ادخل إلى
هذا العالم حيث يمكن لأي شيء أن يكون مزيفًا ،
أي صورة ، أي صوت ، أي مقطع فيديو ، أي جزء
من النص ، لا شيء يجب أن يكون حقيقيًا ، لدينا
ما يسمى عائد الكذاب ، وهو ما
يمكن لأي شخص أن ينكر الواقع ، من شأنه أن
يتدفق من أدوات الذكاء الاصطناعي الجديدة التي يتم إطلاقها عبر الإنترنت ،
كما يقول الشركات التي تطور هذا
تحتاج التكنولوجيا القوية إلى التفكير في
آثارها السلبية المحتملة ، فلا يوجد
عالم متصل بالإنترنت وغير متصل بالإنترنت ، وهناك
عالم واحد ومتكامل تمامًا عندما
تحدث الأشياء على الإنترنت ، يكون لها
آثار حقيقية على الأفراد في
مجتمعات المجتمعات
للديمقراطيات ولا أعتقد أننا كذلك  لقد
أصبح المجال يتحمل مسؤوليتنا بالكامل
هنا في هذه الأثناء ،
سأستمر في إزعاج زملائي هنا ،
هذا الشيء الذي قاله أندرسون أنني كنت أفعل
هذا منذ وقت طويل ويجب أن أقول إن توني
أوسوليفان ربما يكون الأفضل في هذا
المجال  رائع حقًا ، إنه
لطف منه أن يقول حقًا ، أنت تعلم أنه
يجب تكريمك حقًا ،
لن أقول أبدًا أنه
لا يمكنك ذلك ، لذا هذا أمر رائع
بالنسبة لي ، إنه أمر مضحك ،
إنه أمر مخيف أيضًا ، أعني كما أشرت  في
هذه القطعة ،
يمكنك أن تأخذ صوت شخص ما يتصل
بأمك وأنت تعلم أن هناك بعض
الاحتيال ضدها قائلاً إنك في
ورطة وتحتاج إلى القيام بتحويل الأموال
على الفور ، نعم ، أعني أن والديّ
لن يعتقدان أبدًا أننا لطفاء جدًا
من  الهاتف لهم مرة أخرى مثلهم ، هل
هذا حقًا دوني
أم ، لكن انظر كما تعلم ، لقد استمتعنا قليلاً
بها ، لكن هذه التكنولوجيا
قوية جدًا لإنشاء المزيف العميق
لك ، نحتاج فقط إلى دقيقة أو دقيقتين من
الصوت  أمر لا يصدق ويمكنك
البدء على الفور في كتابة وضع الكلمات
في فمك ،
نعم يبدو واضحًا بينما ندخل في
انتخابات 2024 ، فكر في الدور الذي
لعبه الصوت في الحملات السابقة في
شريط Access Hollywood أه شريط Romney
أه النسبة المئوية وحتى نوع  تقوم
Watergate بتسجيل كل هذه
الأشياء ، كما ذكرت
نوع عمليات الاحتيال التي تقوم بخداع الأشخاص ،
فقد أعدت نائبًا تقريرًا حيث
تمكنوا من اقتحام حساب مصرفي
كان له صوت أفكر فيه من
منظور شخص ما  توفي
أحد أفراد أسرته ويريد أن يسمع
صوته يعرف صوت أحبائهم
وحتى تعرف التواصل معهم أن
هذا هو الاحتمال في المستقبل
الذي سيكون من السهل القيام به الآن وكذلك
مع شيء مثل الدردشة gbt حيث أنت
يمكن أن يقلدوا ما سيقولونه بشكل صحيح ،
نعم ، كلاهما معًا ، إنه أمر
لا يصدق ، لا أسمع سوليفان شكرًا
جزيلاً